I did a show at flappers on Saturday
night with Fahim asan and had written
Rapoport came right yeah great show and
so for him and a son so
Fahim from I think he's Afghani and then
Assange from India and so there's been a
constant thing on my on my feet that
that I sniffed on the red light I'm like
the streaming stuff yeah which obviously
I they they know I didn't it was just
something fun for them to do yeah but
whatever streamed snitch yeah and a lot
of that I don't see Jay was telling like
there's no either that's stupid to
believe that he's a I don't know so then
I was the picture for him and son I was
a K I've heard the UFC streams are down
got the two best IT guys in the business
working on it
they just look [ __ ] Indian [ __ ]
that's so freaky he goes do you think we
get hey tango for sure that's so funny I
didn't read the caption that look really
funny they could look more like a night
light to I and Lucas or like in the with
green room I've got my IT guys in the
green room working on those illegal UFC
streams best in the biz so hopefully we
get them right back to us [ __ ]
hilarious and then I put because Jay Jay
goes I went I think the best way to do
is kill it with humor and Jay goes yeah
but some people really think you got the
streams put down with no way so I put PS
there's no way people are stupid enough
to think of the power to get stream shut
down right yes pin is a ESPN is owned by
Disney point your anger at Mickey
they don't play that [ __ ] it was if it
was uh it was just a matter of time per
view number sucks of course ESPN shut
that [ __ ] down because they're like why
are number so bad and then illegal
streaming and yeah right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]